y'all booked a movie theater to like see
the ARs tour yeah we we had to we've
been at a concer I've been I went a
little too many times um but it was just
a fun thing to get to do with our
friends AB all together so oh no it did
look fun um we I want to show this
b-roll so this is video um of the
screening that you had oh no wait oh
there there he is okay wait can I tell
you can I tell you my favorite part my
favorite part isn't even the flip my
favorite part is the drag of the hand it
is like it is like did you just see that
like like do you does he do that often
do you back flip of or the drag of the
hand yeah drag of the
hand he does I mean not like super of
not as often as he used to but he does
flipsy impress our friends just like egg
him on if forever doing something
they're like do the flip and I say do it
for as long as you can I know I'm cuz
once you hit 40 things change it feels
differently today I pay for it the next
day it was rough after that evening yeah
you have to have like liquid courage or
something like okay so I have to ask
about um something else that Taylor
posted so which one we'll figure out um
but here this is this is amazing so this
is a bath night for for one of you right
this is a oh boy this is a bath night
for you guys getting this stuff no yeah
so do you usually bath do you usually
are you into bubbles I'm I'm not the
biggest she she loves baths cuz they're
wonderful yes I have a a little problem
with them it looks like you enjoy
them I was in okay it took me 40 minutes
to set up that bath I was in it for 3
minutes and I got hot and then I'm out
of it and I'm like this is a lot of work
for like 3 minutes in the bath I used
too many bubbles so I was like what do I
do with them I made a hat but all right
all right let's say you're not into it I
got
it
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home